Hey George.
How's it going?
Pretty good.
What is one thing you really like about self driving cars?
But I have one.
Tell us if we'd say that favorite part of the software stack.
The hardware you work out of your garage.
Describe that experience in one word.
That's fake news.
What was the last project you worked on?
Crypto kitties.
If you could spend an evening with one famous person,
who would it be?
Oh God,
I don't know man.
Elan,
come on.
Yeah,
you on.
What do you do to relax?
Nothing.
Life is work.
People you like,
whoa.
I'll tell no last thing you made with your hands.
Ooh,
I don't know.
I put the laces in these shoes.
What's a hard problem?
You're working on self driving cars.
What advice would you give yourself 10 years ago?
Nothing,
man.
I'd be afraid of messing it up.
What's a hard problem you're working on?
You asked that one already.
What website do you waste time on Twitter,
man.
I love Twitter.
It's terrible though,
but not as bad as Facebook.
Last person you emailed.
Oh Man.
Pull my dad.
You get an all expenses paid trip to one city.
Where do you go?
New York.
Yeah,
that's hitting the world.
Where do you go to relax?
No,
I don't believe in relaxation.
This is a scam from the advertising agency.
They're trying to sell you vacations and those kinds of things.
Would you visit marks once they have five star hotels?
What is one thing you can't live without the Internet.
Where do you envision AI will lead us into the future?
What text editor do you use them?
What open source library do you really like?
Ooh.
Flask.
What's one of your favorite movies to Matrix?
What is something you do to come up with project ideas?
Think what is one of your hobbies outside of programs?
Smoking weed.
The first program you ever,
oh man.
It printed out dirty words when I was like three.
I thought it was hilarious.
What's a music genre you're currently into?
We'll peat bro.
Wool.
Peep that.
Emo rap programming.
Language of choice for Ai Development.
Python.
Favorite professor?
Ooh,
I don't know.
I don't know that many professors.
Jeff Hinton.
I mean I guess,
but that's like just the first thing that comes to mind.
Recency bias.
What is one area of Ai that interests you?
A lot.
I wish reinforcement learning worked.
What is a misconception people have about self driving cars?
That the trolley problem matters?
Maybe 1%.
You really admire
Elon Musk.
What's the most beautiful thing in the world?
Oh nature.
What do you want to work on the most?
I want to fight nature.
And when,
what are the people you've met at AI?
I've never been to an AI conference except us.
Now describe an ideal culture in one word.
Self reflective.
What is one thing that really excites you?
The future?
Best advice you've ever received.
Uh,
don't start a company which the bravest thing you've ever done and I don't
believe in that.
Who's your favorite computer sciences?
Uh,
I mean,
look,
they were geniuses but tiring,
like,
you know,
genius back in the day.
Do you think you need a phd to do Ai Development?
Uh,
will the singularity happens?
Absolutely.
What is one area of Ai that doesn't get enough love?
Replicate ability of results.
What's one of the most surprising things you've learned from your studies about
Ai?
Uh,
I view the whole world that way now.
I view the whole way I view myself as an AI agent.
I think about like data efficiency and like all the same concepts apply to life.
What is the meaning of life to win?
What was the last thing that frustrated you?
Just in general,
like typing is very frustrating.
I used computers really fast and I'm even frustrated by how fast I use
computers.
What's your spirit animal?
I don't know.
If you had a time machine,
when would you visit?
Oof,
oof the future.
And I take stuff and I'd come back here and be really rich and sell it.
Tell me a secret about yourself.
Just one.
Oh,
um,
I don't have secrets.
Who is one person you would love to collaborate with?
I don't know what that word means.
Collaborate.
Favorite Linux distro you bond to.
Have you ever been in love?
What's the best cryptocurrency to invest in a theory and turn complete,
Bro?
Have you built an APP with blockchain that you'd use in your day to day life?
Absolutely not.
What's something you've learned in the past month?
I've learned in the past month,
I think I saw behavioral cloning.
Do you think will create mainstream decentralized apps in your lifetime?
Yeah,
I think it's going to get more and more mainstream.
If you were in the world,
what is one law you didn't act?
Repeal a lot.
Red,
deaf,
speak green deaths all the time.
What's a problem that you would love to see?
Soft
governance.
What's a risk that comes from AI?
Bad Governance.
Who is one person you looked up to when you were,
say five years younger?
Five years younger.
I don't believe a member of the past that much.
What were you like as a kid in grade school?
I don't really remember the past that much.
What resource do you use the most to learn about the latest breakthroughs in AI?
Twitter.
What's something that excites you about the future?
Ai.
Girlfriends.
Do you believe in the concept of marriage?
The concept?
I believe it exists.
What'd you get married?
No.
Have you ever been married?
All right,
George,
thanks for answering those questions.
Excellent.
All right.
Have a good one.
Cool.
Thanks.